Ты либо растёшь и процветаешь, либо
деградируешь и умираешь. Ну кольвич, я
вот про смысл хотел просто небольшую
историю рассказать. Тогда, когда вы
сломали концерт ёлки, когда не поехал в
университет, поехал пости Баранов. Ты не
можешь трансровать пустоту, если в тебе
нет смысла. Таким образом ты становишься
уникальным, не похожим ни на
кого. Всем привет, с вами Маргулан
Сизимбай, и это беседы. Сегодня мы будем
вести беседы, а на тему личного бренда и
проявленности. Напомню про формат.
Формат очень простой и древний, такой
же, как древнегреческая философия. На
самом деле я этот формат взял у древних
греков, когда к Аристотелю, Платону,
Сократу приходили ученики, либо
приходили любые люди с улицы и могли
задавать вопросы, беседовать с ними на
разные темы. И наш формат такой же. Мы
будем говорить на разные темы, обсуждать
разные темы. А я
собираю интересные для аудитории вопросы
и приглашаю желающих людей, которые
хотят побеседовать со мной. И у вас,
кстати, у зрителей есть такая
возможность. Поэтому, если вы хотите
побеседовать со мной, если у вас есть
интересные темы, на которые можно
поговорить, либо интересные вопросы,
оставляйте заявку внизу по ссылке, и
если вы пройдёте по всем критериям, мы
обязательно вас пригласим. Ну а сегодня
у нас на беседу пришёл Коля Пак. Коля
Пак это Николай Пак. Мы с ним знакомы
давно, один из моих учеников, он
проходил мою группу
наставничества. А продюсер много лет,
творческий человек, а сейчас э блогер,
быстронабирающий обороты, поэтому
рекомендую его канал тоже. Спасибо
большое, Коля, приветствую тебя. Да,
здравствуйте, Гон Колич. Давай
побеседуем, да, большое спасибо за
возможность, которую вы даёте. Я вообще,
честно говоря, для меня большая честь э
с вами разговаривать. Ну, мы часто
разговариваем, но разговаривать так,
чтобы публично. И отчасти тоже большая
ответственность, потому что те вопросы,
которые я вам задам, я я думаю, что
интересуют и моих зрителей, и, мне
кажется, ну, и ваших, и вообще зрителей,
те, кто вообще всех активных людей,
которые хотят что-то изменить в своей
жизни. Здесь важно ещё напомнить нашим
зрителям, формат беседы не подразумевает
вопрос ответов. Это не просто как
интервью. Вопрос задали, я должен только
чётко ответить и так далее. Беседы
подразумевает это просто беседы,
разговоры о об определённой теме.
Поэтому не обязательно вы получите
ответы на все свои вопросы, но вы
поприсутствуете на обсуждении. И, вы
знаете, очень часто инсайты получаешь не
от самого вопроса, а от самого процесса
обсуждения. Поэтому мы будем обсуждать,
и я буду оставлять специально
пространство для того, чтобы вы сами
додумывали многие вещи, чтобы вы сами
включались в этот формат, в эту беседу.
Угу. Ну давай начнём. Коля, о чём
сегодня хотел бы поговорить? Да, Маргон
Колич, я вот в одном из наших разговоров
вы про контент. как-то сказали, что
какая главная задача контента - это
раскрыть все грани уникальности, ну, как
бы личности, да. Вот. И поэтому тема,
которая меня интересует - это личный
бренд, проявленность и вот поиск
уникальности. Если можно, ну, чтобы было
как бы понятней, расскажите, пожалуйста,
вот личный бренд, ну, как вы его как бы
понимаете, почему он важен? Потому что
вы, я помню, вы говорили, что личный
бренд, во-первых, нужен каждому
предпринимателю, нужен ли он вообще всем
и вокруг чего нужно строить личный
бренд, ценность личного бренда. Можете
вот на эту тему давайте поговорим. Ну,
давай порассуждаем. Ну, смотри, мы
говорим личный бренд, и личный бренд
зачастую может вводить в заблуждение.
Угу. А что такое личный бренд? Вот
представь. Во-первых, давай поймём. Мы
все хотим достичь каких-то успехов. Мы
все хотим достигать каких-то
результатов. Так вы, да? Так вот, для
того, чтобы достигать каких результатов,
мы должны понимать, что все результаты
приходят через людей, да? То есть, по
сути, любой успех - это продвижение по
социальной лестнице, да? Это мы не в
одиночестве живём, это продвижение по
социальной лестнице в обществе. Если ты
политик, ты начинаешь с низов. Растёшь,
растёшь, пока не станешь президентом
страны. Если ты бизнесмен, начинаешь с
какого-нибудь киоска, а, и растёшь, пока
не станешь миллиардером. Если ты певец,
начинаешь там на гитаре у себя меж перед
друзьями пейти, пока ты не станешь там
очень крутым певцом и так далее. Но это
всё продвижение по социальной лестнице.
Так вот, для того, чтобы продвигаться по
социальной лестнице, а людей сейчас
немало, 8 млрд людей в мире, прежде
всего нужно же познакомиться, потому что
ты же никогда не взаимодействуешь с
человеком, которого ты не знаешь, да? Ну
ты же взаимодействуешь только с теми
людьми, которых ты знаешь. Ты же не
подходишь на улице к людям и говоришь:
"А давай я тебя куда-нибудь продвину".
Да, да, да. Поэтому нужно познакомиться.
А что такое познакомиться в социальных
сетях, в этом в мире онлайн, в
онлайн-мире? Угу. Это бренд. Потому что,
смотри, а ты можешь просто прокричать,
сказать: "Меня зовут Коля, давайте
знакомиться". Никому не интересно. Да.
Соответственно, для того, чтобы ты стал
кому-то интересен, ты должен не просто
прокричать: "Я Коля, Пак" и так далее,
ты должен создать бренд. А что такое
создание бренда? Создание бренда, а
начинается вот с чего? Когда у тебя в
твоей деятельности есть определённый
смысл, да, ты знаешь, для чего ты
живёшь, ты знаешь, для чего ты
занимаешься тем, чем ты
занимаешься, то у тебя есть что сказать
людям. Угу. Да. Так вот, бренд
начинается с того, что ты сначала должен
обрести смысл того, чем ты занимаешься,
а потом начать транслировать это людям.
Потому что что такое смысл?
Смысл - это твоя версия той
деятельности, которой ты занимаешься.
Вот ты говоришь: "Я продюсер". Да. Ну,
продюсеров много, соотни тысяч людей
продюсеров в мире. А чем ты лучше, хуже
других? Ты можешь быть лучше или хуже
других, только одним своей
уникальностью. Да. А как ты людям
докажешь свою уникальность? Только
смыслом. Ты говоришь: "Ребята, я не
просто продюсер, я продюсер, который
топит за свободу творчества". Да. за
свободу творчества. Я потому что, а,
проблема творческих людей в том, что их
съедает рутина, их съедают
административные вопросы, финансовые
вопросы, там, налоговые вопросы,
юридические вопросы и так далее.
Продюсер - это тот человек, который
освобождает творческих людей, даёт им
свободу, да, свободу творить. И вот это
и есть мой вклад. Оба, ты сразу другой
продюсер сразу. Да ты уже не тот,
который просто на творческих людях бабки
зарабатывает, ты уже другой продюсер, ты
А люди любят по покупать или
взаимодействовать с людьми, которые
несут смысл, да, потому что люди же
хотят менять мир. Соответственно, если
будет один продюсер, который просто
занимается своим делом, как
зарабатывание денег, а второй говорит:
"Я освобождаю творческих людей от вот
этой ненужной рутины".
Вот смотри, если я хочу менять мир к
лучшему, то я лучше куплю у этого
продюсера, потому что он освобождает
творческих людей от рутины. Поэтому
бренд - это всегда первое сначала
нахождение смысла в той деятельности,
которой ты занимаешься. Второе
трансляция этого смысла. А потому что
иначе ты не запомнишься, просто скажешь:
"Я Николай Пак, ну, продюсер, ну, таких
много". А вот
просертосм творчу
такой зверника.
Поэтому трансляция своей уникальности и
экспертности.
Угу. Это трансляция
смысла. Ты транслируешь, получается,
свою уникальность через смысл. А
транслируешь свою экспертность и
благодаря этому получаешь доверие. Угу.
Уким образом, бренд равно смысл плюс
доверие, плюс охваты. Угу. Или
количество подписчиков. Ну вот такая
пирамида. Сначала ты, а у тебя должно
быть большое количество охват, то есть
потому что если ты тебя не показывают
другим, как ты это Угу. дальше уровень
доверия, но это всё объединено смысл
такая арматура, которая вот это всё
держит. У да. И поэтому бренд - это это
с точки зрения мм того, как формируется
бренд. А если с точки зрения
потребителя, ну, конечно, бренд - это
то, как люди тебя
воспринимают. Или, как сказал Джефф
Безс, бренд - это то, о чём о чём и как
люди говорят, когда вас нет. Угу. О чём
и как люди говорят о вас, когда вас нет.
Ну, я это называю по-другому. Например,
это вот представьте для бизнесменов
особенно, чтобы легче понять. Вот
представьте, говорю, вот есть физический
супермаркет, куда вы пришли с полками
товаров, а есть супермаркет в голове у
человека представление. И и важно
понять, э какой полке твой товар там
находится. И вообще в его голове твой
товар есть или нет или ты Да. Вот важно
застолбить место вон там в его
голове. Вот это бренд. Ну очень классная
метафора. Я я вот этот я теперь вашу
метафору возьму. Я в основном все у вас
беру. Я обычно, знаете, как рассказываю?
Я говорю: "Ну, во-первых, говорю, в
голове надо у человека появиться вообще,
туда попасть хоть как-то, потом как-то,
ну, ваш силуэт должен быть более чётче и
чётче, но это прямо круто. Да, полкать
по получит. Проблема в том, что люди
плохо запоминают имена, да? А люди плохо
запоминают профессии, да? А люди
запоминают смыслы, потому что в каждом
из нас, а смысл он триггерит нас. Да,
да, да. Мы люди. А вообще, что такое
смысл? Смысл - это основная ценность в
нашей жизни. Основная ценность. Почему
смысл нас тригрит всех? Потому что смысл
- это основная ценность в этом мире.
Приведу пример. Ты знаешь, что наша даже
наша жизнь ничто по сравнению со
смыслом. Потому что жизнь, лишённая
смыслом, бессмысленная жизнь, никому не
нужна. Да. Почему люди суицидом
заканчивают? Потому что они заканчивают
тогда, когда теряют смысл жизни. Когда
теряют смысл жизни, ему неинтересно
становится ни богатство, ни бизнес, ни
жизнь, ничего. Вот это самое страшное,
прожить бессмысленную жизнь. Поэтому
смысл - это то, что придаёт ценность
нашей жизни. И смысл - это то, что
придаёт ценность всему, всей нашей
деятельности, всем нашим товарам, бренду
и так далее. Поэтому смысл - это основа,
а уже на основе этого смысла ты
формируешь впечатление людей о себе, и
это становится брендом.
Круто. Авич, а можете вот также вот всё
вот как сказать, как вы вот умеете, ну
вот про свой бренд рассказать, какой
смысл и как как выглядит ваша структура?
А, но я же не профессиональный, э, там,
э, маркетолог, либо это, ну, ну, ну,
как-то же для вас сформулировано это. А,
а, смотри, с точки зрения бренда я, а,
какой смысл транслирую и для кого
транслирую, да? А вот есть 8 млрд
человек. Угу. Во-первых, я чётко
понимаю, что я не для всех. Угу. Я
таргетируюсь или целюсь только на тех
людей, которые хотят чего-то достигать.
Угу. Если вы всем довольны и ничего не
хотите, тогда это не ко мне, да? То есть
я только к тем людям, у которых есть
мотивация и стимул что-то менять в своей
жизни. Да. Поэтому я транслирую для тех,
кто хочет
саморазвиваться в любой сфере: бизнес,
там инвестиции, хоть какой. Сначала вот
я целюсь на этих людей. Это в первую
очередь. Поэтому а каким образом я это
делаю? Я делаю это через свою миссию.
Моя миссия звучит так.
Я исследователь, да? И моя миссия звучит
так, что я пришёл в этот мир для того,
чтобы исследовать законы этого мира,
выявлять из них эффективные и делиться
результатами своими своих исследований с
людьми. То есть, что я делаю? Я исследую
законы эффективности, я применяю законы
эффективности и я обучаю законам
эффективности.
И в процессе исследования у меня
возникает очень много мыслей, много
контента. И я людям делюсь: "Если вы
хотите добиться, то надо вот это делать.
Если вот это, то вот так. Эффективно это
делать. Вот так вот. Это неэффективно.
Вот это эффективно. Как принимать
решения, как там делать выбор и так
далее, и так далее". Таким образом,
а если брать А для кого я? Я для тех,
кто хочет расти, кто не удовлетворён
текущим положением. Первое. Второе,
какой э смысл я транслирую? Я транслирую
смысл, что а эта жизнь в этом жизни есть
два состояния. Ты либо растёшь и
процветаешь, либо деградируешь и
умираешь. Вообще само слово жизнь - это
асыство с ростом. Жизнь равно рост. Если
ты не растёшь, значит, ты не
живёшь. Соответственно, я для тех, кто
хочет расти. Угу. И вот я транслирую,
если вы живёте, то вы должны расти в
личном плане, в финансовом плане, в
социальном плане, неважно. И смысл,
который я транслирую, я говорю два
основной смысл и подсмыслом. Первый
смысл: раз ты живёшь, значит ты должен
расти, да? А под смысл звучит так: если
ты растёшь, то должен ты делать это
эффективно, да? Потому что неэффективный
рост - это лишняя потеря энергии,
времени и и так далее.
Поэтому вот я транслирую. Какие смыслы я
транслирую? То есть с другой стороны,
смотрите, Магон Коливич, у вас, вы
говорите, вот 8 млрд, оно не для всех,
вроде бы, потому что только для тех, кто
хочет что-то менять. А с другой стороны
предложение как бы оно как будто бы для
всех, потому что, ну, ты же не хочешь
умирать, условно говоря, деградировать,
да? Просто смотрите, да, есть же периоды
даже у разных людей бывает так, что
бывают периоды, когда человек хочет
расти. Угу. Бывает человек, когда
находит успокоение. Дело в том, что мы
же люди, мы волнами. Пока нас сзади не
клюнет проблема, мы не растём вообще. Мы
люди по инерции стремимся к остановке.
Да. Если нас не беспокоит, если у нас
проблем не будет, то мы предпочитаем не
расти, потому что рост подразумевает
затраты энергии. То есть базовые
настройки мы не не хотим. Мы стремимся к
состоянию покоя, да? То есть посмотреть
даже в быту, что мы хотим на диван, на в
кресло либо на диван. Ну то есть мы
хотим сразу занять позу неподвижности.
Так вот даже мы своих достижений
каких-то мы хотим там вот я этого всего
достигну и буду сидеть, ничего не
делать, буду то
просто один из драйверов, один из
драйверов наших стремлений к достижению,
чтобы мы воспринимаем достижение как
ступеньку запрыгнул и дальше ничего не
делаешь. Да, да. Так вот, мы стремимся и
делаем для того, чтобы потом ничего не
делать. У нас даже в голове вот так
сложно. Мы даже делаем для того, чтобы
ничего не Да, по сути, чтоб потом ничего
не делать. Парадокс. Да. Да. Так вот 8
млрд, я говорю, не все, потому что 8
млрд человек не все хотят расти в
единицу времени. У сейчас хотят расти 4
млрд. 4 млрд на диване. Не хотят ничего.
Уже добились всего. Им всё достаточно.
Кайт. Потом у этих 4 млрдов эти
достигают каких-то результатов. Теперь у
этих проблемы, теперь эти хотят расти.
Таким образом, одновременно не растут
все 8 млрд. А, ну то, что они живут, это
значит, что они чего-то хотят, да. Но
просто периоды
у этих, у одной 4, по- 4 млрд, им нужно
срочно что-то, а у второй, пока всё
нормально, они достигли, они хотят
наоборот отдыхать. Угу. Потом происходит
наоборот, эти достигают, успокаиваются,
теперь эти хотят что-то нового. У них
либо проблема случилась, либо хотят
вдруг захотели ещё больше. Таким
образом, по сути, хотят расти все 8
млрд. Да. Дада. Вот я. Но они просто это
делают по очереди. Раз разные это Да. А
вот получается, ну и как бы ээ и должно
быть, как должно быть в голове у
человека есть полка, например, нужно мы
хочу расти. И кто мне в этом поможет?
Ну, один из тех людей, которая должна
ассоциироваться со словом рос, например,
это вот Маргулан Сесимбай, например. Да,
как как бренд тогда помещается. Да,
смотри, дело в том, что в голове,
представь, в голове у человека есть
такой супермаркет, где полка каждая
полка - это смысл. Угу. Одна полка
называется саморазвитие, другая полка
называется зарабатывание денег, третье -
инвестиции,
четвёртое качество жизни. Пятое-
здоровье. шестой и так далее. И очень
важно понять, на какой полке в голове ты
у него находишься. Должно быть так:
среди ночи его будешь и говоришь: "Так,
ээ, назови челове лучшего человека или
эксперта по саморазвитию, да, или там и
он должен сразу тык и сразу сказать, да,
вот это значит у тебя есть бренд, когда
ты человека ночью разбудил и говоришь:
"Да, давай назови быстро". Это такое
короткое позиционирование, да, с чем ты
ассоциируешься, ну, с чем человека, да.
Дело в том, что люди, а не могут и не
хотят запоминать просто имя человека и
профессию, как я сказал. А, но как
только ты связался с их смыслом, полкой
в голове, да, всё, ты насмерть у него в
голове стоишь, он уже тебя забыть не
может. Да, поэтому на важно заякориться
у него в голове с определённым смыслом.
Да, это вот это и есть бренд. Именно.
Почему вот крутые бренды здесь смотришь,
они не товар свой показывают, они смыслы
показывают эмоции, а образ жизни. Вот
что они хотят передать, да? То есть вот
передача смыслов - это основа бренда,
да? Блин, ну очень круто. А ну я вообще,
ты знаешь, с детства я всегда тяготел к
идеологии. Я думал даже в советское
время, если бы Советский Союз
продолжился, то я бы, наверное, был
идеологом. Угу. Коммунистическим, может
быть, идеологом. Потому что я вообще
очень сильно поглощён идеологией. Я
считаю, что а без идеологии жизнь пуста.
То есть я вообще вот когда меня призвали
там коммунистическая партия там пости
Баранов, я да забросил на свои
перспективы, не поехал в университет,
поехал пости баранов. Ну я в этом плане
такой. То есть вы считали, что это вот,
ну это надо, в этом смысл есть, да? Да,
есть смысл, надо, надо идти. Я такой
романтик, идеолог и так далее. И когда я
управляю своими компаниями, я никогда
человеку не говорю что-то делать, пока я
ему не объясню, до тех пор, пока у него
не загорятся глаза. Это вот у меня бзык
такой. Я не могу, я могу, конечно,
например, сказать: "Так, возьми быстро
что-то сделай". Ну я не могу себе место
найти. Я понимаю, что он либо накосячит,
либо не то сделает, либо Поэтому, если я
прошу его что-то сделать, я сажу и
говорю: "Так, сделай вот это, потом вот
это". Ты понял, что нужно делать? Смысл
вот в чём. Цель такая-то, смысл
такой-то. Ты понял, в чём смысл? Понял?
И если это будет, то будет мне будет вот
это, тебе будет вот это, будет всем
хорошо и так далее. И другим людям
хорошо. И пока глаза не загорятся, я не
отпускаю. То есть это моя фишка. Я люблю
так общаться с людьми. И бренд, на самом
деле, это продолжение моей личности.
Ведь не невозможно создать бренд на
пустом месте. Если ты не такой, Угу. то
ты не можешь бренд создать. Ты не можешь
транслировать смотри, ты не можешь
транслировать пустоту, если в тебе нет
смысла. Смысла твоей деятельности ты ещё
не нашёл, а смысла своей жизни и так
далее. А это первое. И второе, ты не
можешь транслировать чужую, чужое
содержание, да? Ты можешь транслировать
только самого себя. То есть получается
уникальность она всё равно внутри тебя.
То есть это распознать в себе эту
уникальность. Она не может быть там я
выбираю уникальность вот эту вот. У, ну,
конечно. А Всевышний нас создал всех
разными. А у этого же тоже есть причина,
для чего он осоздал всех разными. Чтобы
каждый нашёл именно свою нишу. Это же,
ну, представь, такая экосистема, да, и
каждый должен заниматься своим делом,
да, там букашки, таракашки своим, птицы
своим делом. Каждый это и тогда только
выигрывает всё, вся экосистема.
Кокольвич, я вот про смысл хотел просто
небольшую историю рассказать нашим
зрителям. Она была вот на недавном слёте
в Дубае.
Тогда, когда вы сломали концерт ёлки,
когда вот там была такая история, в
общем, выступала ёлка на слёте, вы уже
выступили, всё, короче, выступала ёлка,
все танцуют. Ёлка - это певица, да? Да,
высыпала ёлка, да, певица. Вот и мы
стоим, и Маргон Коли что-то вышел в
коридоре в фае. И мы с каким, я не
помню, с Рафаэлем, по-моему, задали ему
вопрос про смысл. как раз-таки Макет
стал говорить, и, честно говоря, начала
происходить магия, потому что он
сам Аргулан Каливич в своём содержании
говорит, потому что, говорит, смыслом ты
можешь мотивировать, ты можешь как бы
поднимать людей. Вот мы про диалоги
рассказывали, и я чувствовал, как вокруг
нас вот так вот толпа разрастается, люди
уходят с концерта ёлки, и вокруг нас
просто фая толпа, все вот так снимают,
все вот так слушают. И и вы мне вот так
вот говорите, и смысл пойми, что
происходит. И я вижу визуально, как это,
как сказать, знаете, как Интерстеллари,
как изменяется реальность материальная,
потому что он говорит: "Ты открываешь
дверцу". Говорит, смыслом ты можешь
открыть дверцу, и люди могут как бы это
я смотрю вокруг люди реально это
происходит. Ну вообще это было
удивительно. Смысл это, я ещё раз
говорю, смысл - это то, что придаёт
ценность всему. Да. Вот э
а приведу такой пример. Вот есть
японская философия называется Кенцуги.
Кенсу. Она переводится примерно как
красота в
ущербном. Красота в ущербном. Откуда это
произошла философия? А дело в том, что
раньше самые лучшие фарфоровые чашки
готовили в Китае. Угу. Поэтому бы и
посло название чайна. Самый лучший
фарфор. И китайский император подарил
японскому императору набор, чайный
набор. Но потом у них началась война, то
всёё и поставки прекратились. А сервиз
со временем начал падать, ломаться,
разбиваться и так далее. И они что
делали? Они склеивали
чашечки. И со временем получилось, как
когда этот фарфор передавали из
поколения в поколение, они начали
говорить: "Смотри, а вот эта трещина,
вот эта бабушка, когда получила известие
о смерти деда, она уронила на пол чай,
сервиз, и вот этот чашка вот так
лопнула, разбилась". Это потом мы
склеили. Это бабушкина это. Угу. И
японцы заметили такую вещь, что в
какой-то момент оказывается старые битые
вещи становятся гораздо дороже новых.
Да. Да. Для них исполь. И они начали
ценить вещь с трещинами, склеенный и так
далее. И появилась
философия красота в ущербном. Угу.
Потому что с точки зрения новость новых
вещей, это ущербно, там трещины, поломки
и так далее. Но с точки зрения смыслов
теперь-то это уже не чашка,
теперь-то это моя история, да, это моя
эмоциональная связь с
бабушкой. Это традиции нашей семьи, да.
Это представляешь, сколько в чашке одна
чашка сколько смыслов передаёт. Да. Это
связь, это свидетель вообще событий,
которые происходили. Это свидетель
событий. Это свидетель событий. Это
эмоциональная прямая связь меня с
бабушкой. Она из этой чашки пила. Да.
Это свидетель смерти моего дедушки.
Понимаешь, сколько в чашке. И они начали
ценить их настолько. И вот появилась эта
философия Кенсуги. Угу. Так вот, заметь,
вещь сама по себе ни о чём, да. Вопрос в
том, что какой
смысл этой вещи придали события и
интерпретация людей об этих событиях.
Да. Вот когда швейцарские часы
рекламируют, что там отец отвёрточкой
закручивает болтики, а рядом сидит сын,
и он говорит: "Из поколения в поколение
мастерство
передаётся". Он они как бы в рекламе
говорят про мастерство мастера, которые
он обучает ученика, но потребительно,
да, клиент думает, из поколения в
поколение передаются часы. Дада. Да. Ну
как бы он так свою свой свой смысл
вставляет, понимаешь? То есть есть в
предмете определённый как бы смысл он
наполняет. Это в принципе очень много
предметов искусства уже тоже в это даже
не в этом. Смотри, в предмете-то смысла
нет. Да, в предмете просто есть
определённая категория людей, которая
может находить смыслы в предметах. Да.
Да. Можешь находить этот кофейный столик
или Людовик пил там это. Ты знаешь, ты
же, наверное, у тебя у самого есть
знакомые, друзья, которые умеют вкусно
рассказывать. Да. Ну да. Вы вы классно
рассказываете, да? А я, например, именно
могу вкусно рассказывать, потому что я
очень часто, когда я про какую-то еду
рассказываю, все сразу хотят кушать. Да.
А, но это вопрос не только про еду. Это,
ты знаешь, да, про любую вещь можно так
рассказывать. И вот в этом и есть суть
бренда. Потому что когда вот
предположим, я хочу вот этот микрофон
продать, ну, человек смотрит, это металл
здесь какой-то этот губка чёрного цвета,
ни о чём.
Но когда я хочу продать, я должен
сделать так, чтобы потребитель посмотрел
на этот микрофон моими глазами. Угу. А
для меня микрофон - это не просто
микрофон. Например, если я деятель
искусства, я говорю: "Вы знаете, ребята,
откуда форма этого микрофона появилась?"
Форма этого микрофона появилась с Элвиса
Прести, когда он то-то и то-то. Он пошёл
на концерт такой-то, обычно микрофон не
сработал, он это сделал такой-то. А
потом появилась вот эта компания,
которая основал друг Элвиса Пресли. И он
был фанат звукорежиссёра Элвиса. И пошёл
историю рассказал, всё, микрофон уже
другой. Да, хочется им обладать и
хочется быть сопричастным. И тебе
хочется именно не обладать не железкой,
с губкой, а именно вот этим микрофоном,
понимаешь, с вот этой надписью, брендом,
да? Понимаешь, потому что обезличенный
микрофон - это просто железка с губкой,
да? А микрофон с историей - это уже
смысл, да? Это уже причастность,
причастность к великому. И это и есть
бренд. Почему люди за бренд готовы
платить больше? Возьмите женские
сумочки. А в чём смысл женских сумочек?
переносить вещи, губнушку, там какие-то
женские вещи. Ну, блин, почему некоторые
стоят 300.000 300-400.000 долларов сумка
Бирки, например, на аукционе. И такую же
сумку можно купить за 1.000 долларов или
за 100 долларов. Но люди же покупают.
Почему? История. Смысл. Только смысл.
Вот разница в сумках. Посмотришь, в чём?
Нету разницы. И эта кожа, и эта кожа.
Размер такой же. Вот эта сумка даже
больше по объёму. Да, с точки зрения
функциональности никакой разницы. Угу.
Разница только в том, что вот в эту
сумку вставили смысл и она стоит 300.000
долларов. А в эту сумку смысла не
вставляли, поэтому она стоит 100
долларов. Да. В эту сумку вставили смысл
и его донесли до как бы, да, то есть то
есть что люди зна как быстно люди ещё
приняли это. То есть, ну, бренд - это
донесённый смысл, да?
А это классно, то есть донесённый и
принятый людьми смысл, да, потому что
люди должны его ещё принять. Ну то есть
человек, условно говоря, который на
необитаемом острове жил, там, не знаю,
там поколениями 200 лет он придёт, для
него это не будет ничего значить,
условно говоря. Нет, ты можешь хоть
сколько ему толдышить про мастерство и
поколение он не поймёт. Да, Лагон Кович,
ну, личный бренд нужен всем или не нужен
всем всё-таки? Ну, смотри, м, личный
бренд,
конечно же, я, как мы говорили, раз мы
живём в социуме и мы хотим добиваться
чего-то, то, ну, как мы не можем не
познакомиться с людьми, если тебя нет в
сети, ну, в современном мире, я говорю
про онлайн, если тебя в сети нет, то
тебя и нет.
А как с тобой разговаривать? Вот я
буквально вчера разбирал один кейс. Один
парень, бизнесмен, у него большой завод
производит керамические изделия, и он
говорит: "Китайцы меня убивают, потому
что они дешёвые, продают и так далее, и
так далее". Я говорю: "А ты, у тебя есть
целевая аудитория? Ты с ней как-то
общаешься?" Он говорит: "Нет". А и как,
говорю, вы конкурируете только ценой? Я
говорю: "Вот получается, вы с целевой
аудиторией общаетесь, вы просто
общаетесь через сцену". М. Да. А это
способ коммуникации, да, через сцену,
да? Ты мне говоришь, что у тебя качество
лучше, у тебя оборудование лучше,
итальянское, у тебя глина лучше, всё
лучше у тебя, долговечнее. А что ты мне
это говоришь? Почему ты это не говоришь
своим потребителю? Если бы ты это донёс
до своей целевой аудитории, он бы был
готов заплатить больше, чем за
китайский. Да ну, ты же себе рот
завязал, да, и у вас конкуренция
происходит такая, ты
говоришь: "У меня товар лучше". А они не
слышат. А всё, что они видят от вас, две
цены и у китайцев дешевле. Ну,
естественно, они будут выбирать
китайцев. Бренд - это донесённое
сообщение, смысл донесённый до людей. А
если ты не донёс, что жаловаться?
Соответственно, если человек что-то
хочет, что-то хочет поменять в своей
жизни, то есть, а, все возможности
приходят через людей, одно из
эффективных методов - это просто через
бренд знакомиться с просто быть узнанным
через у большего количества людей,
условными гово, да, бренд и вызвать
доверие в том. Ты смотри, когда ты
здороваешься, есть два варианта. Либо ты
сам формируешь мнение людей о себе,
тогда это бренд. Либо они сами формируют
мнение о тебе, тогда это не бренд. То
есть пустоты нету, как бы, да, ты гово
Да. Смотри, вот это не есть три
состояния. Первое состояние нет, когда
тебя не знают вообще, да? Три состояния.
Первое, тебя не знают, да? Второе тебя
знают, но благодаря тому, что ты донёс,
либо благодаря тому, что они сами
додумали. Дадада. Да, всё, вариантов
другого нет. Соответственно, что тебе
выгоднее? Тебе очень важно, чтобы тебя
знали, потому что если тебя не знают, то
ты ничего не товара, никакого товара,
ничего не продашь, да?
Соответственно, тебя не знает. Это самый
невыгодный вариант. Да. Теперь из
вариантов, когда тебя знают, тебе же
выгоднее донести самому, да, то, как ты
хочешь, чтобы о тебе думали, чем они
сами додумают. Угу. Вот когда ты
доносишь это через смыслы, это и есть
бренд. И вот в моём случае у меня не
было цели прямо, а, формировать какой-то
бренд. Я просто транслировал в этот мир
то, чем я сам наполнен. А транслировал я
две вещи, два смысла, как я говорил.
Первое, если вы хотите жить, то надо
расти, да? Если жить хотите полноценной
жизнь, чего-то добиваться и так далее,
надо расти. А если вы хотите расти, то
надо делать это эффективно. Да. Всё. Ну,
две вещи. И благодаря этому у меня и
подписчики появились, и пишут, что я
приношу какую-то пользу им и так далее.
Ну вы сейчас же, ну, я так не могу не
тему Ютуюба, это же выпуск тоже на Ютбе
выйдет. Вы же сейчас номер один
бизнес-блогер по количеству подписчиков.
Ну, я не сильно заморачиваюсь по этому
поводу, да, я как я как метрику, да,
отслеживаю, но не заморачиваюсь по этому
поводу, потому что там много нюансов.
Важно то, насколько доверяют люди. Я
больше на это смотрю. А смотрю на кто
моя целевая аудитория, какой процент
целевой аудитории среди всех моих
подписчиков, потому что вот у меня 2 млн
подписчиков, но не все они моя целевая
аудитория. Угу. Моя целевая аудитория
всё-таки уже - это бизнесмены и
инвесторы, а их гораздо меньше. Но в то
же время, чтобы,
а, условно говоря, а, зацепить внимание
бизнесменов и инвесторов, сначала надо
зацепить внимание всех, да, потому что
мы же люди, мы идём туда, куда идут все,
да? То есть я к тому, что
предприниматели - это же тоже часть этих
же людей, да?
всем темнит это кон них производт
впечатлея
возникает вам там ну и так далее да это
крутая штука да интересная колевич
смотрите вот не могу не задать этот
вопрос ээ ну общаюсь с многими вашими ну
ровесниками да скажем так вот ты так
подозрительно засмеялся видать мои
ровесники не очень себя проявили не не
вопрос в том,
ээ, ну, ээ, ну, как мне кажется, всё
равно люди, скажут, будем так называть,
ваш, ну, вот ваши ровесники, да, всё
равно, мне кажется, вот если мы говорим
на эту тему, проявленность, да,
опять-таки личный бренд очень, ну,
достаточно, как сказать, с подозрением
относится к таким вещам, да, то есть,
ну, в смысле, э, ну, как вот людям
взрослым, например, да, или людям там,
которые очень закрытые, как бы
проявляются. Это во-первых. Во-вторых,
тоже не могу не задать этот вопрос. У
вас было ли так, что в вашем окружении,
например, ну там, не знаю, как-то в
шутку называли там вас там инфациган или
как-нибудь там что-то вроде такого,
потому что мне кажется всё равно у вас
же есть там старые друзья, вот кто
вотвестники, бизнесмены такие
олдскульные больше. Наверняка у них
какие-то свои представления же о то о
чём, да? А зачем вы проявляете, зачем вы
свой личный бренд строите? А, смотри,
для того, чтобы побудить человека
проявляться и развивать свой личный
бренд. Для этого у него должна быть
нужда. Угу. Потому что если нет нужды,
тогда ээ человек не хочет проявляться.
Дело в том, что все люди, которые ты
говоришь, которые не хотят проявляться,
которые там хотят быть в тени и так
далее, это просто у них ещё нет проблем.
Угу. Как только Ну две вещи: либо должны
быть проблемы, либо должны быть амбиции.
Угу. Две вещи, да. Я тоже хотел
уточнить, если хотят люди расти, просто
даже нужды нет, но хотят расти. То есть
им нужна либо проблема, чтобы они
захотели расти. Ну что такое рост во
время проблемы? Это выйти из той
ситуации, в которой он находится. То
есть его не, да, не устраивает та
ситуация, в которой он находится. Второе
- это нужно амбиции, когда ты говоришь:
"Нет, это не мой уровень, я хочу
больше". Угу. Так вот, э когда человек
не хочет проявляться, это на самом деле
больше говорит об этом человеке самом.
Угу. То есть это говорит о том, что у
человека не осталось ни амбиции. Угу. А
свои бытовые проблемы он порешал. И это
на самом деле плохо, потому что, как я
говорил, в мире бывает только два
состояния. Либо ты растёшь и
процветаешь, либо остановился, как он
думает. На самом деле остановки не
бывает. Либо деградируешь и умираешь,
либо откатываешься, либо Да. Ну, потому
что мир этот устроен таким образом,
когда ты стоишь, ты на самом деле не
стоишь, ты деградируешь. Угу. Посмотри,
даже автомобиль новый купи в гараж
поставь. Через год посмотри, у него шины
уже потрескались, резина потрескалась,
сальники потрескались и так далее. Даже
красота уже не актуальна очень, да. Этот
этот мир, а делает так, что он стремится
к энтропии, к хаосу. Всё деградирует.
Всё время уничтожает всё. Да. Поэтому
когда ты вроде думаешь: "Я стою на
месте", на самом деле ты не стоишь, ты
деградируешь. А это то, что касается
проявленности личного бренда. Поэтому не
надо таких людей просто агитировать,
давать личный бренд, проявленность. Надо
создавать спрос на это. Для этого надо с
такими людьми говорить в плане того, что
а что ты не хочешь больше ничего
добиться? А что, тебя всё теперь
устраивает? Вот даже если тебя всё
устраивает и ты ничего не хочешь
добиться, ну что ты ты выбираешь
деградировать. Угу. Иногда ты должен
расти чисто для того, чтобы поддерживать
уровень качества жизни. Да. Это качество
жизни же это не только про деньги, это
про самоощущения, про нужность, да? А
то, что касательно и инфоцигана,
инфобизнесмена, да, в моём кругу,
конечно, порост меня, ну, в шутку,
конечно, мои старые друзья, старые
друзья называют. Я абсолютно на это не
обижаюсь. Мои старые друзья имеют на это
право. Угу. А поэтому видите, это же а
обидность, не обидность какого-то слова
зависит от самого человека. Это больше
говорит про самого человека. Ну, если я
про тебя буду говорить, что, а, ну, там,
условно говоря, что ты там бегемот, ну,
что ты будешь обижаться? Ты же знаешь,
что ты не бегемот. Ну да, да. Ты будешь
обижаться на бегемота, если ты
действительно на бегемота похож прямо, и
это тебя триггерит. Но если это те ты не
похож, что ты будешь на это обижаться?
Ну, как бы, ну, глупости, глупость. Мало
ли, как не называет. Поэтому а я себя
никак с этим не ассоциирую. Поэтому эти
слова меня вообще не за не задевают.
Угу. Милан Колич, а, ну вот я почти
уверен, что у вас есть определённые
какие-то алгоритмы, потому что вот вы вы
и нас учите, да, что вот алгоритмы - это
одна из один из таких инструментов, да,
которые можно, ну, таких инструментов
развития, да, эффективно двигаться,
скажем так. Ну вот раскрытие своей
уникальности мы, ну, как бы вы отчасти
этот вопрос как бы раскрыли. Ну, то есть
наверное нужно понимать, ээ, для чего ты
вообще живёшь.
кае-то инструменты, которые можно, ну,
например, там, не знаю, завтра я начинаю
там проявляться, завтра открывают там
Instagram аккаунт там или YouTube канал.
И вот уникальность. О'кей, вот я
посмотрел это видео, Магн Колич уважаю,
всё сказал, уникальность, что делать,
как бы, такой, ну, и уникальный, там,
лобзиком пилю, там, я не знаю, на велике
катаюсь там.
Вообще для создания бренда, для своей
уникальности самый лучший подход - это я
это называю режим пейджера. Я, знаешь, я
много много лет работал в режиме
пейджера. То есть я транслирую в мир то,
что я считаю нужным. Я не обращаю
внимания на то, что мне пишут, то, что
там хейтят или не хейтят, или там мнение
других людей, это их мнение. А у
уникальности есть одна хорошая черта.
Она ээ кристаллизует аудиторию. То есть
те, которые разделяют твои ценности, они
очень сильно начинают к тебе тянуться. А
те, кто не разделяют, они начинают очень
сильно хейтить, потому что ты чужой для
них. Да. По и проблема в большинства
людей, почему они не хотят развивать
бренд и не хотят развивать свою
уникальность распаковывать? Потому что
они боятся хейта. Они боятся
общественного мнения. А общественного
мнения человек боится. и хейта боится,
когда человек не наполнен, когда он не
видит смысла, когда в нём внутри нету
смысла, он не видит смысла в том, чем он
занимается, соответственно, его мнение
шатается. Его мнение, ему сказали: "Ты
дурак". Он думает, что он дурак. Ему
сказали, что ты и инфациган, он думает,
что он инфациган. А если у него есть
чёткое понимание, для чего он живёт,
понимание своей миссии, смысла того, че
он делает, ему пофиг, что они ему
говорят. Угу. Понимаешь? И вот
уникальность, как раз уникальность
человека зависит, это же не только
физические параметры, руки длиньше, ноги
длиньше или ещё что-то. Это одна часть.
Но люди, как правило, клюют не на эту
уникальность, а люди клюют на
уникальность смыслов, которые ты
транслируешь то, ради чего ты живёшь,
что ты делаешь, а почему ты это делаешь.
Потому что всем интересно узнать, а
почему именно ты делаешь это? А почему
это делаешь именно ты, а не кто-то
другой? А почему ты это делаешь именно
так? Угу. А не по-другому? Понимаешь, у
людей куча
вопросов. Вот это и есть уникальность. А
для того, чтобы раскрыть уникальность,
ты должен это вот эти вещи понимать. А
когда ты понимаешь, тебе пофиг до
мнение, что о тебе говорят.
Соответственно, ты не обращаешь внимания
на хейтеров. Ты работаешь в режиме
пейджера. Ты транслируешь то, что ты
считаешь нужным, и таким образом ты
становишься уникальным, не похожим ни на
кого. Да, потому что, а, самая
безопасная среда - это быть обычным
человеком, да? А что такое быть обычным
человеком? Это постоянно выполнять и
делать то, что диктует тебе
общество. То, что общество диктует. Вот
выполняй. Будь как все. Вот даже будь
как все. Это самая безопасная позиция.
Будь как все. Но если ты будешь как все,
то ты и проживёшь жизнь как все. А жизнь
как все, в основном-то проживает серую
жизнь. Да,
поэтому яркую жизнь надо
заслужить своей смелостью, не побоявшись
распаковаться. Именно за уникальность
люди платят деньги. Вот. А уникальность,
как я сказал, уникальность выражается в
уникальности твоего смысла. Лавич, вот
вы рассказываете, я прямо вижу картинки.
Это же по сути это же вот про наше
сообщество отчасти. У это
коду у нас
вброятия
коби и вот вот то, что вы говорите, вот
вы, ну, кристаллизуется как бы вот своя
уникальность, и какие-то определённого
рода люди, они больше, как сказать,
примагничиваются, что ли, ну, с разной
степенью, да, то есть это нельзя
сказать, что вот прямо вот одни такие,
как на подбор, но они все с разной
степенью. Опять-таки, ээ, инсайт этого
интервью, например, в разные этапы
времени, в разные периоды, да, они как
бы примагничиваются. Те, кто хейтит, они
остаются дальше, да, и получается, по
сути вот эта вот уникальность. И если
дать ей охваты, чтобы вот, ну, как это,
условно говоря, ну, не золото, как
правильно назвать, ну, типа что-то вроде
золота, нужное нам золото, нужно нам
металл просеять, его нужно как можно
шире как бы вот этими брендами, охватами
охватить. И условно говоря, вот эти
крупинки, они вот как бы будут
примагничиваться, да, вот примерно такие
картинки. Даже ты даже заметил,
наверное, в кайзинг клубе, вообще в
наших сообществах такая ситуация. Тот,
кто себя не проявляет, тот как бы
пришёл, ушёл, даже никто его не
замечает, да? А кто ярдко проявляет,
прямо к нему тянутся люди, да. Ну вот ты
в своё время даже когда пришёл, ты тоже,
ты же заметь, ты уникальный тоже с
творческой среды пришёл в среду
бизнесменов.
Вот этот сам факт, даже это был смелый
шаг, и люди вначале тебя с
недопониманием встретили, но при этом
точно невозможно забыть. Это ты
единственный творческий был среди
бизнесменов, да? А и а теперь уже и
бизнесмен среди творческих.
Поэтому видишь, уникальность,
уникальность важна. Именно уникальность
создаёт
смысл благодаря тому, что уникальность
возможна благодаря смыслам, которые ты
транслируешь. Да. У меня ещё был
маленький такой пример. У нас слёт
Стамбуля был. Я очень хотел на него
попасть. И, короче, если вы, может быть,
не помните, я, короче, я сломал ногу
перед слётом и и на слёт я приехал.
Тогда огромное количество людей же
приехало. А я пропустил слёт в Анталии и
в Стамбуль приехал. И меня вот этот
Айдар Окенов вместе со мной, они возили
меня на коляске. И многие люди даже
думали, что я, ну, не ногу сломал, я всё
время, ну, я колясочник. Он говорит:
"Нифига себе, вот это воля". К это так
хотел попасть на слёт. И, ну, и я,
конечно, тогда запомнился. Я после этого
меня все помнили, все ко мне хорошо
относились. Я такой: "Ага,
зафиксировал". Следующий слёд я делаю
так. Первый день я очень необычно
одеваюсь. Что-то там типа все в
пиджаках, а я такой в футболке яркой
этот, а во второй день обычный одевайте,
короче. Ну это такой, да, тоже просто
такой забавная история, как бы бренд
вообще очень э большая, глубокая тема,
да. Конечно, очень трудно раскрыть всё
это за 45 минут. В целом, а об этом
можно говорить очень много. Она такая
захватывающая, интересная тема, потому
что, а, вот если посмотришь, это, причём
не то, что изобретено недавно, а веками
уже, тысячелетиями бренд, если вот в
раскопках находишь старые керамические
изделия или старые ножи, там есть клейма
мастеров. Клейма мастеров. Но для чего
они это делали? Чтобы уникальность,
подчеркнуть свою уникальность. Вот мой
меч, который или мой нож, который я
делал, он уникальный, он не похож на
другие. А почему?
Вот просто если знак поставить, человек
покупает меч или нож, этот знак ни о чём
не говорит. Он начинает с ним
разговаривать этот знак только тогда,
когда я получил информацию, слухи о том,
что этот мастер использует технологию
домаских мастеров, там
бла-бла-бла-бла-бла. Каком-то тамплиером
каким-нибудь принадлежал этим, да. Да. И
он поставщик императорского двора. Да,
да. Тогда только вот этот знак на ноже я
я воспринимаю как ценность. О. О, тогда
во знак. О, блин, это зна это не это уже
не просто нож. Ну, колевич. Ну, это же
ещё везде и получается и контент. Вот
такой нож, например, вы пьёте ко мне,
например, в гости, да, по сути вот мы не
знаем, мы, конечно, можем во многом у
вас вы много есть что рассказать, но,
например, вы приходите, я вот этот нож
вытаскиваю, это же тоже по сути, я же
вам потом начинаю рассказывать.
Смотрите, клевич, какой у меня нож. И
вот это тоже я тоже начинаю уже
пересказывать тот контент, который мне
заложили в этом бренде, когда я покупал
по сути дакой сидите тоже и по идее и
слушаете и такой: "О, ничего себе вот
датей, да, да, тоже, может быть, хотите
или ну или вообще". То есть это же А вот
это как раз и ценность смысла в этом и
заключается, что смысл он передаётся,
да? Смысл он очень виральный. Ага.
Потому что, как я говорил, смысл придаёт
ценность любой вещи, да. Так вот, что
делает человек, когда получает какую-то
ценность? Он сразу хочет поделиться этой
ценностью с близкими, друзьями. Да. Да.
Ну почему? Потому что ты же хочешь перед
ними очки заработать, да? Кого-то
отблагодарить, потому что кто-то с тобой
поделился, да? Соответственно, ты
начинаешь делиться. И вот это природа.
Или ещё можно это масштабировать этот
опыт. Знаете, я там машину купил, потом
вам рассказываю, как я купил машину,
потому что я заново хочу пережить эти
эмоции, когда покупал машину там,
условно говоря, да, это тоже же или
путешествие рассказывают тоже. Или вот
бывает о бывает у машин тоже разная
история, когда это и у меня даже был
такой случай, когда а я ходил и у меня
палки вот эти скандинавские, и я
рассказывал про палки, что очень
полезно. Ну как без задней мыслей, что
это полезно. потому что на 30% снигает
снижает нагрузку с колен и так далее. И
рассказывал, какие палки купить. Говорю:
"Вот эта модель самая хорошая, потому
что она немного амортизирует, можно
подошву менять и так далее". Я говорю, я
их проверю палка они надёжны. Я вот на
килимаджара с ними ходил и так далее. И
так рассказывал, что ребята хотели эти
палки купить у меня конкретно вот эти
палки, да. Они говорят: "Поставьте на
аукцион классные палки". Я говорю:
"Блин, это обычные палки". Не, говорит,
теперь это не обычные палки.
Такая же история же была в Исландии. Вы
же нам на этом на планшете на обычном
лицке бумаги, обычным фломастером вы нам
нарисовали вот эту схему, ну там вот
секрет миллиардера, да, тогда и пацаны
начали биться за Я тоже хотел этот вот
этот листок бумаги в какой-то момент
обрёл смысл, потому что вы его на нём
нарисовали, и ты сначала там Саня
двинулся за пакетом, потом Серёга, потом
я тоже хотел, но я там уже не успел.
Короче, он мог, в принципе, тогда пацаны
могли продать этот листок, да, это
интересно. А коль я смотрю тайминг время
подошло, к сожалению, время пробежало
очень быстро. Большое спасибо. А, и у
нас не получилось, может быть, а можете
получилось поговорить полностью о
бренде. Бренд - это большая вообще тема,
но я хотел бы, резюмируя, подчеркнуть
одно, то, что нужно, наверное, запомнить
всем, всем, кто не только бренд, а свой
раскачивает, личный бренд, проявляется,
что самое главное в этом мире - это
смысл. Смысл придаёт ценность любой
вещи. и в том числе вашей жизни, потому
что жизнь, лишённая смысла,
бессмысленная жизнь, никому не нужна.
Поэтому смысл - это основа всего. И если
вы хотите стать успешным бизнесменом,
если вы хотите раскрутить крутой бренд,
а старайтесь найти смысл во всём. смысл
своей жизни, смысл своей деятельности,
смысл в том товаре, который вы
производите аа в каждом объекте. Смысл
найти можно везде. И это, на самом деле,
самое недооценённое сокровище. Смысл
заставляет людей двигаться, достигать
каких-то целей, аа там переживать
эмоции, жертвовать своей жизнью и так
далее. Поэтому живите, друзья, со
смыслом, ищите смысл, находите смысл и
поднимайте ценность своей жизни и того,
чем вы занимаетесь. Коля, спасибо тебе
за вам большое спасибо. Очень классный
разговор состав. Ну, для меня это была
реальная беседа. Я, честно говоря,
некоторые вопросы даже забыл. Я бы
реально спрашивал то, что прямо меня
очень сильно интересует. Я в какой-то
момент забыл даже, что мы в студии
находимся. Ну, ты знаешь, формат беседы,
с одной стороны хорош тем, что он
достаточно гибок.
В какой-то момент мы, наверное,
чуть-чуть перешли в формат интервью, в
какой-то момент беседы, но это такой
неуловимый формат, и он демократичный
формат. Здесь можно говорить немного,
отходить от темы,
немного по-другому говорить и так далее.
Но мне это и нравится. Беседа в этом в
этом есть что-то такое тёплое,
дружеское. Вообще в беседе есть смысл. И
даже когда я представлял формат, я же
сказал, что этот формат прост
и древний, так же, как философия древних
греков. Для чего я эту фразу сказал?
Чтобы люди сразу уловили смысл, да,
смысл этой беседы. И у нас не было цели
ответить на все вопросы. Э у нас была
цель показать беседу и вообще сам ход
рассуждений. Я надеюсь, что мы смогли
показать это.
мы смогли задеть какие-то важные вещи. И
одна из самых важных вещей и результатов
таких бесед заключается в том, чтобы это
вас спровоцировало и подвигло начинать
размышлять в этом направлении. Если у
нас это удалось, я был бы только рад.
Поэтому напишите в комментариях,
поделитесь этим видео, если было
интересно. Ставьте лайки,
подписывайтесь. Всё по стандартной
схеме. До следующих встреч. Пока.
Спасибо большое. Спасибонч.